>>Jeff: Hi everyone. I just want to welcome
Nathan here. A really pleasure to have him.
The cookbooks are the most amazing cookbooks.
I don't even know whether to call them cookbooks
that I've ever seen in my entire life. So
Nathan, can I first start out by saying do
we call these cookbooks?
>>Nathan: I call it--
>>Jeff: Come on over here.
>>Nathan: Yes. I call it a cookbook.
>>Jeff: OK.
>>Nathan: Now, it's in six volumes, admittedly.
But it started off in my mind as being one
volume. So I think of it as a cookbook.
>>Jeff: OK, so cookbook's all right. Well,
you got a little presentation.
>>Nathan: OK.
>>Jeff: I'll talk to you after that.
>>Nathan: Cool.
>>Jeff: And you're welcome.
>>Nathan: OK, well thanks. So I just wanted
to tell you a little bit about the book. There's
some fun facts we have on it. Six volumes,
2,438 pages, 1.1 million words. If you put
those in a single line of text, it will be
seven and a half miles long. It's not clear
why you'd want to do that, but we thought
it was a cool statistic.
We took 150,000 pictures and 3,200 of them
were good enough for the book. That's actually
a good ratio, believe it or not. 1,522 recipes,
72 chefs from around the world gave us recipes
to use in the book. We had six research cooks,
full-time, for three years. Forty-four writers,
editors, and art staff altogether.
Forty pounds, and my favorite statistic, four
pounds of ink. When you get a book made, the
printers make a blank book. And so I said,
"Well, gee, how close is this to the real
book?" And they said, "Well, it'll be about
a half-inch thicker and four pounds heavier."
And I said, "Why?" They said, "The ink." I
said, "You're kidding me."
And they said, "Well, actually if you think
about it, a full page photo is about a thousandth
of an inch of ink on it. Most of our pages
have photos. A thousandth of an inch times
2,400." It's a thick block ink. And one of
the questions that I always get, so I'll just
anticipate it here is, I'm a digital guy,
why am I talking about ink at all? Why don't
I have it as a digital thing?
And there's two reasons. The first reason
is we made a decision about what platform
to target about two years ago. And we figured
that's what it would take to do the first
version. And two years ago, there was no iPad.
There was only Kindle. And here's one of the
pictures of the book. The Kindle version is
just pathetic 'cause it's small and it's black-and-white,
and it's not made for images.
The iPad version is better, but even so, you
would have to do amazing amounts of pan and
scan and lots of work to take these very large
beautiful photos that we've done and try to
adapt them for online. Eventually, we'll do
that. But to me, the reason to do it isn't
because I wanna make a cheap version, or a
more portable version.
They both have some value. It's to make a
really cool version that uses interactivity
in lots of ways. Then, pretty much, it starts
being a software project and we'll get to
it, but after the print version. The other
reason we did it, frankly, is that today,
paper-based book is still the best way to
get this material out to the people that are
interested in it.
So we did a lot of work to make sure that
the quality was very high. You can see that
the industry standard is about 175 lines.
That's considered a very good half-tone screen
for color reproduction. A really good art
book has 200.
But there's no reason to have those fixed
grids anymore if you have computers. So we
used something called stochastic screening.
Stocastic screening gives you just a ridiculously
better-looking photo with effectively the
same printing technology. We also made sure
we had great inks. So, industry standard inks
have lots of out of gamut colors.
There's colors you can take a picture of with
a digital camera that you can't possibly reproduce
in the ink. So here, you see the difference
all the gray areas in watered colors that
don't reproduce. The reason we obsessed about
those things is that we think the presentation
is important.
If you went to the French Laundry or Manresa
or some other great restaurant and they served
you on paper plates, plastic forks, the food
would be the same but the presentation would
suffer. So we wanted to make sure that all
of the book was at the same quality level.
So now I'm just gonna walk through a little
bit of what's in the book. Volume one is called
"History and Fundamentals," and that's what
it's about.
It's mostly material you'd never find in a
classic cookbook. But part of our idea here
is there's a set of techniques and recipes
and methods and knowledge that the world had
developed over the course of the last 10,
20 years, which is very hard to learn. If
you wanted to learn the techniques in the
book, you'd have to work at a restaurant like
El Bulli in Spain.
I was there last week. Or the Fat Duck, I
was actually there this week. Actually, no,
it was last week. Last week. Or, early last
week. So, you have to work there for a couple
years before you would see some of the techniques
and even then you wouldn't get all of them.
Some of the techniques come from food science
labs.
They come from all over the place. But I realized
that these techniques have been developed,
but there was no good place to learn them.
There was no good place they all came together.
And besides the actual techniques and the
mechanics of doing the cooking, there's lots
of background information. What is the history
that motivates this?
What's the science behind it? So, we cover
all kinds of things in there going all the
way back, actually, from fire, all the way
up to the history of modern cooking. We cover
things like--well, we've got some slides--we
cover things like the physics of food, how
heat moves through food, so forth. Volume
Two is called "Techniques and Equipment."
And so, it takes a different view of food.
It's about, as it says, techniques and equipment.
And it starts with about a 200-page chapter.
So, almost a whole book, that's about traditional
cooking. We go through every technique in
traditional cooking. We explain how it works,
what are the physical principles behind it.
'Cause a classic recipe tells you, "Do this.
Do this. Do this." And you get a result. And
if you don't care why, or you don't want do
why, that's enough. But it's hard. If you
want to deviate from that recipe insight as
to why you're doing the things, is really
important.
So, the point of this volume is to say, "Here's
the insight behind how those techniques work,"
so you can understand it well enough that
you can go cook in your own way, or if you're
not into cooking, you can do it just because
you're curious about it. People ask me often,
"Who is this book for? Is it for professionals?
Is it for home cooks?" And I always say it's
for people who are passionate about food,
who are also curious about it. If you're not
curious, then I don't have much of a proposition.
If you are, I think there's some cool stuff,
even if you don't cook. Volume Three is called
"Animals and Plants." It takes an ingredient-oriented
view of cooking.
And, of course, the two most important ingredients
are plants and animals. So in this chapter,
we go through the structure of meat. We go
through why some cuts of meat are tough and
why some are not. We go through all of the
different aspects of plants and we have lots
of recipes and techniques for dealing with
those.
Some of them are classic. But mostly, we stayed
away from the classic techniques, 'cause lots
of books have that, and we focused on the
really new interesting ones that lets you
do stuff you couldn't any other way.
I should say what I think "modernist cooking"
means. And we really view it as two things.
One is a style of cooking that breaks some
of the traditional rules of cooking to let
you do things you couldn't do any other way.
And the second is using brand new techniques
that break those rules, even if you're achieving
a traditional outcome.
So some of the food in the book is wild stuff,
like you'd find at some of these restaurants,
like El Bulli in Spain that may not even look
like food or it looks like Klingon food. There's
other things where the outcome is totally
traditional, either traditional Western food,
and we also have recipes in the book from
Chinese, Japanese, Indian, and other cuisines.
So, it doesn't matter what the outcome is
so much as how you got there. And that's what
we focus on. Volume Four is called "Ingredients
and Preparations." Here, we look at ingredients,
but ingredients other than meat versus plants.
Ingredients like thickeners. A huge part of
traditional cooking is about how to make a
sauce thick, or how to give body to a soup.
There's some traditional ways to do that.
There's some modern ways. Gels are another
topic we cover. Now, one kind of a gel is
cheese. Cheese is a protein gel made by coagulating
milk. Tofu is protein gel, made by coagulating
soy milk. So, we cover those. We cover gelatin,
but we also cover lots of brand new kinds
of gels because chefs have found ways to use
these gels in lots of interesting fashions.
Finally, we cover coffee and wine but in a
somewhat irreverent way. Coffee is one of
the great beverages, but is really given short
shrift by most chefs. And I'm from Seattle
and in Seattle we obsess over coffee. One
of the things I say in the book is a Michelin
three-star restaurant is often serves coffee
that wouldn't be fit for a Seattle street
vendor.
And it's really true. There's a set of people
who obsess about food and will go to any length
to get the ultimate food. There's another
set that obsess about the ultimate coffee.
And pretty much, they're two different sets
of guys. And so, the point of this chapter
is bring them together. We also have a chapter
on wine that takes a science-oriented view
on wine, trying to demystify it.
Wine is almost like a secular religion. There's
a whole ceremony associated with it. There's
this whole notion of connoisseurship. One
of the techniques we discuss in the book is
something we call "hyper decanting."
This is where you take a bottle of wine, particularly
a younger red wine, you should all try this
at home, you pour it into a blender and you
hit frappe and you frappe the hell out of
it for 30 seconds or so. Let it calm down.
Then, pour it in. It achieves what decanting
achieves, but way more so. Now there's two
reasons to do this.
One, is for a younger red wine, it makes it
much more drinkable. And in most cases, in
a blind taste test, we preferred the hyper
decanted to ordinary decanting it right from
the bottle. But the other reason we do it
is it freaks wine people out so much.
[laughter]
Oh, my God. You go and you pour this great
bottle of wine into the blender and hit the
switch and they look at you like you're a
complete lunatic. But it works.
[laughter]
So, Volume Five is the first volume in the
whole book that actually looks like a cookbook.
We've got about 1,500 recipes in the book.
The "Plated-Dish Recipes" volume takes about
50 recipes and goes--49, I guess--and goes
in-depth in them to give not just the main
thing you're cooking, but the garnishes on
the plate and in most cases, the entire rest
of the meal.
So as an example, we went nuts on barbecue
'cause I love Southern barbecue. I actually
competed once in World Championship of Barbecue.
And we actually won. But not due to me. I
was like the lowest ranking guy on the team.
So we developed nine barbecue sauces for the
book. And then, we developed recipes for cornbread
and baked beans.
Essentially, an entire barbecue meal. And
that's one of those 50 things in here. Now,
one of the things that we thought was a huge
value to our book was the use of cool pictures
to both illustrate things you couldn't otherwise
show people, and to get people excited about
concepts that might seem a little dull and
boring.
So this is from our section on canning. And
if you have an acidic vegetable, in this case,
pickled vegetables, you can do what's called
"boiling water canning." And this is our photo
for boiling water canning. We use this idea
of a cutaway throughout the book to try to
illustrate the magic view of what's happening
in your food while you cook it.
As you can see, we not only cut the pot in
half, we cut the jars in half, too, 'cause
what the hell. We have lots of photos in all
kinds of ways. This is a centrifuge jar. We
use a lot of interesting equipment in cooking.
A centrifuge subjects the liquid to a force
equivalent to about 40,000 times Earth's normal
gravity.
That causes things to separate out. In this
case, this is a sauce we made. This is actually
a Hungarian goulash. It separated into eight
layers by density. Now, you might say, "Why
do you want to do that?" I'm sure that there's
lots of reasons.
You can take all kinds of food products and
spin it in these centrifuges to achieve a
clear consomme, or some other thing like that
that you just couldn't get any other way.
That also brings up a question. How much of
this can you do at home? I say out of 1,500
recipes, at least half are easy to do in the
home.
If you're willing to buy a little bit of equipment,
but nothing too exotic, just stuff you can
get at Williams Sonoma, or some other mall
cooking store, it's maybe 75 percent of the
book. And the last 25, good luck because that's
when you need to get liquid nitrogen dewars.
[laughter]
No, seriously. We have a whole section, "Cooking
with Liquid Nitrogen." It's fantastic. Unless
you make stuff super cold, without making
it wet. Whereas ice, of course, doesn't let
you do that. And that last 25 percent, you
can do at home.
I do it all at home. But it's gonna require
a little bit of effort. Here's something where
we're using a torch to sear things. This is
pomegranate seeds. Here's another one of our
cutaway photos. This is a traditional pot
roast in a Dutch oven. This is enzyme-peeled
grapefruit. It turns out, there's an enzyme
called Peelzym.
And you can soak citrus in it and it only
attacks a special pectin molecule that's in
the outer thing. So you soak it in there and
it all pulls off. But it also makes it look
cool. This is potato starch in a potato. The
purple things are the actual starch granules
and the blue lines are the cell walls of the
potato. Here's an example spread where we
show what's going on.
This is actually the first picture I took
for the book to see if this cutaway thing
would work. And it kind of did. This is steaming
broccoli. So all of the little text boxes
around the outside explain what's going on.
What's happening with the boiling? What's
happening with the condensation? How is it
heating? Up in the corner, there's a box that
describes the difference between boiling and
steaming.
In theory, steaming ought to have much higher
heat transfer. In practice, it actually doesn't
for a bunch of reasons we explain in the text.
It's actually slightly slower to steam broccoli
than it is to boil it. Here's our wok cutaway.
Now, we discovered why people don't cook with
half a wok, here.
[laughter]
This caught fire three times while we were
doing it, because there's actually no trick
to this. We were cooking with a wok that was
cut in half. Now, not exactly half. We cut
about a third of it off, but the oil kept
going in the fire and it would catch fire.
But we had this great motto: It only has to
look good for a thousandth of a second.
[laughter]
And so, a lot of these photos, people say,
"Well, what's the trick? Aren't you using
Photoshop?" And well, every digital photographer
uses Photoshop, but mostly the trick is willingness
to make a mess. Here's that same picture now
where we can zoom in and see a bunch of the
different text things explaining it.
Here's our barbecue cutaway. So those coals
are just sitting there at the edge. That's
really cut in half and they kept falling off,
but again, it only has to look good for a
thousandth of a second. What we explain here
is all of the things that go on in grilling
hamburgers. And it turns out, there's lots
of interesting dynamics.
Those drops of fat that fall are crucial because
those flare-ups produce most of the characteristic
grilled flavor. You get a different flavor
from grilling like this than if you broil
it from the top, even with the same amount
of heat. The reason is, from the top you don't
get those fat fires happening. This is how
you cut things in half.
This is our machine shop. My company has a
whole laboratory where we prototype inventions
that we come up with. And this is our shop.
And we decided to build our kitchen laboratory,
where we made the book, right around the corner
from this. So whenever we wanted to cut something
in half, we come over here.
Here is a short video. This is a wire EDM
machine. And we've got a pot coming in. Wire
EDM uses very high electrical current. It
makes tiny sparks. You can see them there.
The whole thing happens underwater, believe
it or not. And those tiny sparks jumping off
this brass wire, actually will cut any kind
of a metal or conductive surface.
So you come out and voila. We have cut the
pot in half. We had other machines we would
use to cut glass in half or all kinds of other
things. So, there's some of the things cut
in half. Actually, we have two halves of one
of the best kitchens in the world. They're
just not together anymore. You can see with
the one pot there, a technique we used to
keep stuff in, we glue a piece of Pyrex in
front of the pot.
Now that gives you a little glue line, but
there, that's where Photoshop is handy 'cause
you can photograph the other side of the pot.
When you cut it in half, you get two halves.
So you photograph the edge in the same position
and then you can swap it in. It's a lot like
a Hollywood movie where a guy flies through
the air supported by a wire, and then they
digitally take the wire out.
Here's one of our nerdier parts of the book.
This is our chapter on heat and energy. So,
we have partial differential equations in
the cookbook. The cookbook has the strange
distinction that I wrote thousands of lines
of code to write the cookbook, 'cause we used
lots of computer simulations to understand
things like heat conductivity, like the diffusion
of a brine.
If you brine a meat, that's also run by a
diffusion equation. So, tons of code were
written to write this book and here's some
of the equations. Here's another example of
things. Suppose you've got a barbecue. Well,
as you move away from the hot surface, the
heat falls down, right? And if you move far
enough away, there's hardly any heat at all.
But what does that curve actually look like?
Well, we calculated it. Most of the heat is
not coming from hot air there. It's coming
from infrared rays and so, you can calculate
how much radiation is emitted. It's important
not only for how the heat varies as you move
vertically, but how even is the heat as you
move side to side.
And that funny horn-shaped thing is what we
call the "sweet spot." That's the zone for
which the side to side heat variation isn't
more than about ten percent. So, if you want
the best results, that's where you should
be grilling. Here's an example of a step-by-step
technique. This is one for making hamburger,
believe it or not.
One of the philosophies we had with the book
is that any dish that is worthy of a cook's
attention, is worthy of refinement. So we
set out to make the ultimate hamburger. Now,
our idea of the ultimate hamburger may not
be yours. And you might wanna just run to
the In-N-Out Burger and get something really
quick and that's perfectly fine.
But if you care about a burger, you can lavish
as much care on a burger as you could on some
otherwise very fancy French dish that involves
foie gras and 50 ingredients. In this case,
the key is a technique in how you grind the
burger. 'Cause believe it or not, the alignment
of the grain matters.
So what we're doing here is we're trying to
align the grain so that if you see the cut-in-half
burger, all of those tubes of meat that get
pushed out of the grinder, are all vertical.
And that means when you bite it, it crumbles
better.
And crumbling, or being very tender, is important
in the sandwich 'cause when you pull away,
you don't want to pull away and leave the
burger pulled out of the rest of it. It's
gotta all come down directly. So here's the
close-up of the technique of how you align
the grain. It's very simple. But once you've
tried it both ways, this way is better.
Here's the actual burger. It's a wonder what
you can do when you suspend gravity. Here,
in the book, we actually cover the recipe
for everything that you see there. The bun,
the sauce, the lettuce is infused with smoke
because that gives you a cool smoky thing
while it stays crunchy. Not only do we show
you how to grind the burger, but what mix
of meats to use for the burger.
And we even know of a cool technique for cooking
the burger that involves liquid nitrogen.
Our idea of an ultimate burger is that it's
perfectly medium rare, edge to edge, but really,
really crispy on the outside. So we do that
by cooking it sous vide, in an unsealed bag,
to a medium rare. Then we put it in liquid
nitrogen for about 45 seconds.
Then we put it into a deep fryer. Now, the
deep fryer makes the outside super crispy.
The point of the liquid nitrogen is that it
freezes and chills enough of the burger that
it doesn't overheat the inside, so you don't
get these big bands of gray. Normally, if
you cook something under high heat, you get
a big band of gray and we wanted to avoid
that.
Come on, you can do it. So, here's a cool
thing. We got a video camera at the lab that--let's
see, oops--so this video camera shoots HD
video at 62 6,200 frames per second. So I'm
gonna go back, actually, and show you the
other. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. So the first
one's a water balloon. And the miracle of
this
is no one's told the water it's time to fall
yet.
The balloon itself is under tension, so it
pulls away very quickly. But the inertia of
the mass, so it's a little bit like when Wile
E. Coyote would run off a cliff and he wouldn't
fall until he looks down. So then in our gels
chapter, I decided to give a recipe for ballistics
gelatin.
[laughter]
'Cause people see it on "CSI," or you see
it on "MythBusters." So what the hell? Why
not have a recipe for ballistics gelatin?
Well, if you have a high-speed camera and
you have a block of ballistics gelatin lying
around, pretty soon someone says, "Hey, let's
shoot it."
[laughter]
This is popcorn, so watch really closely.
Popcorn illustrates a really important principle
about the physics of water, which is when
water boils to steam, it expands by about
a factor of 1,600. So that's what's happening
here. Right now, there's a little bit of steam
issuing from a fissure in the bottom. You
can watch it expand.
It's trying to relieve the pressure, but ultimately
it can't and so it pops. Now this is something
that would be better in an electronic version
of the book. So we did shoot some video for
it, but the sequence of pictures still works.
If you wanna make an omelet, you gotta break
a few eggs. So we did. And, again, this is
the kind of thing that happens when you have
a high-speed camera.
Pretty soon everything looks like it needs
shooting.
[laughter]
So I've got almost infinitely more material,
but I thought at this point, Jeff and I will
talk a little bit and then we can take questions.
>>Jeff: So that was really cool. Thank you.
So one thing I was asking you before you got
started is why didn't you use a food stylist?
And I'd love to hear your answer on that 'cause
I thought it was so good.
>>Nathan: So, we had two philosophies on that.
The first is that part of cooking is presenting.
And if you--. We thought it was our jobs,
the jobs of the cooks and everybody else,
to make the food the way we wanted to see
it. And so, if we went and did that, then
we did our job right. We should just be able
to take the picture.
We shouldn't have a stylist coming to tell
us how to fake the picture and all sorts of
other things. But the other reason is we didn't
want our pictures to look like everybody else's
pictures.
>>Jeff: You don't, really.
>>Nathan: And so, when we set out to do this,
I told one of the people we were interviewing
for art director, I said, "Look, I wanna show
people a view of food that they've never seen
before." And this person is like, "How many
cookbooks are there? How many magazines are
there? How can you do this?"
Well, we found a way to do it. I don't think
we would've found that way if we just had
a professional food stylist do what they do.
>>Jeff: Yeah, 'cause I've never seen anything
like this. It's truly amazing. Another thing,
when we were talking before this, you said
that this actually started out as an outline
for a 400-page book, or something like that?
>>Nathan: Six hundred.
>>Jeff: OK.
>>Nathan: Yeah, so about five years ago, I
realized that there were all of these techniques
out there, but there was no good place to
learn it. And I realized that 'cause I was
learning it. And I'm like, well, damn it.
I wish there was one big definitive place
you could go. And in many fields, there's
a textbook like that.
The big definitive textbook and that's where
everybody learns. There wasn't something like
that here. I thought, "Well, OK. Well, maybe
I'll write it." And so I wrote an outline.
And my first outline from four and a half
years ago is almost the same as the book we
wrote. But, the page budget was 600 pages.
So, we were terrible at estimating.
But this is one of those things where once
we got in, there was no turning back.
>>Jeff: And so, I tried to get your book and
obviously, it's oversold. Do you have plans
on publishing more?
>>Nathan: Sure. Well, I had somebody come
up to me at an event and they said, "Well,
you know I just love your book. It's fantastic,
but your publisher's a complete idiot." And
I said, "Well, actually, I'm publishing the
book."
[laughter]
And yeah, I am an idiot. And on a bunch of
things I always say, "Look, it's the first
2,400-page cookbook I've ever written." And
you know something, it's the first 2,400-page
cookbook the world's ever written.
So we tried to guess what the first printing
should be. And I wanted to print 6,000. Mark,
over there, j'accuse. It's his fault. He wanted
5,000 and we compromised at 6,000.
[laughter]
And yeah, it shows how much pull I have, huh?
And we did all these spreadsheets of how much
would it cost to warehouse them for three
years just in case, and so forth. And we actually
had sold the 6,000 before they even shipped.
So the interest in the book turned out to
be way bigger than we thought. So we've ordered
25,000 more.
>>Jeff: And I told you to get more.
>>Nathan: Well, I put a thing on our blog
asking, just soliciting, lots of input and
say, "Hey, we're trying to decide how many
to print." And so, we had a lot of people
make suggestions and I decided on 25,000.
In about six weeks, I need to make a decision
on whether I add more for this year. And the
big unknown there is Christmas, 'cause Christmas,
of course, you sell a whole lot more than
before. But usually, the way people model
that is they model that on a baseline, where
you say, "OK, if this is the baseline, I'll
sell about five times more during the month
of December than I would baseline."
What's my baseline? Is my baseline the incredible
sales we've had now, or is there just 7,000
or actually, we're up to about 9,000, 9,000
lunatics that want the book and that's it?
And we won't sell another single one.
>>Jeff: [inaudible]
>>Nathan: OK, well good. On the way here,
I was thinking, "Boy, this is a really dumb,
another one of these dumb publisher moves.
I'm coming to talk to a bunch of people who
get three excellent meals a day provided by
you, so why should they buy a cookbook?"
[laughter]
>>Jeff: Speaking of fabulous meals, you mentioned
that you've eaten at the Fat Duck and El Bulli.
What is your favorite restaurant? Do you have
one? What's your favorite meal? Do you have
a favorite meal?
>>Nathan: So, I like lots of different kinds
of food. And I don't have a single favorite
meal. The most interesting restaurant in the
world, by far in my view, is El Bulli in Spain.
I love the Fat Duck, I love lots of other
things, but El Bulli changes its menu totally
every year. They're only open for six months
of the year.
The other six months of the year, they are
doing R&D to develop new recipes. The bad
news is that it's closing in June for good.
So, that's why last week, I went.
>>Jeff: So, after--
>>Nathan: This, too bad. Our kitchen laboratory
popped up, there. If it pops up again, I'll--
>>Male Audience Member #1: I heard you performed
an experiment to understand barbecue stall
better.
>>Nathan: Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #1: I would like to
hear you expand a little bit. It sounds like
you cook one--
>>Nathan: Right.
>>Male Audience Member #1: in a sous vide
container and that that heated up significantly
faster.
>>Nathan: OK. So let me give a little background.
So, if you Google "barbecue stall," S-T-A-L-L,
you'll get a few links that are about a stall
that sells barbecue, like at a state fair.
But if you say "barbecue stall temperature,"
you'll get literally thousands of hits, because
one of the great mysteries of barbecue is
called "the stall."
And here's what happens. You cook a brisket,
or a pork shoulder or whole hog, some big
piece of meat, and you watch the temperature.
And initially, you put it in and the temperature
increases, increases, increases, then it stalls.
And it's way below the temperature of the
air in the barbecue. And it stays stalled
for hours, two hours, four hours, sometimes
even more.
Then, it starts going back up again. So, what
the hell is the stall? And these thousands
of pages on the 'net are all about people
trying to explain what the stall is about.
And the usual explanation is that what's happening
is the collagen in the meat is being converted
into gelatin and that process is what makes
tough meat tender.
It's also what makes stock that you cook for
a long time, like veal stock, unctuous and
rich. And it makes it gel up if you let it
get cold. Well, that process was surely happening,
but I realized there was nowhere near enough
energy in that reaction, that it could take
all of that heat out. And so it had to be
something else.
So, I realized there's only one thing that
it could possibly be and that's the evaporation
of water. That in fact, what you're doing
is you are drying out your big piece of meat
and it's something called evaporative cooling.
The same reason you feel cool when you get
out of a pool, unless it's a 100 percent humidity
outside.
So in fact, what was happening is that you
would go through a long period of drying.
Then as soon as the outside was dry, then
the temperature could start going back up.
So to prove that, we did an experiment where
we took one brisket, cut it in half. One of
them, we sealed in a plastic bag, just so
there would be no evaporation.
You could also seal it in aluminum foil. We
tried that, too, and it doesn't make any difference.
And so we put them both in there. We had temperature
probes stuck all over both of them. And we
put them into a convection oven. That let
us control the temperature better than a real
barbecue. We could have also done a barbecue,
but the same thing would happen.
Sure enough, the one that was uncovered stalled
for about two and a half hours and then it
went back up. The one which was covered up,
no stall at all. And any collagen, anything
like that, would be in both of them. So, we
sort of, I think definitively, showed that.
>>Male Audience Member #1: Was there more
humidity in the oven when you cooked the one
that was uncovered?
>>Nathan: So we also had a thermometer in
the oven, and what's called a wet-bulb thermometer.
So this measures the actual humidity. So what
happens is the humidity of the oven initially
goes up, then over a period of time the humidity
goes down because there's some air venting
out of the oven.
So, this is all about rates. You're gonna
evaporate from a certain rate in the meat
until you get such a dry crust on the meat
that you can't evaporate at that same rate
anymore. Meanwhile, you have another rate,
which is the rate at which water is coming
out of the oven. Now one of the really funny
things about this is when you're in the middle
of the stall, the traditional wisdom is slather
more sauce on.
But this is like trying to heat something
while you run a garden hose on it. OK? The
more sauce you put on, the more there is for
evaporation. So instead of stalling for two
hours, you can make it stall for as long as
you want it if you just kept pouring water
on it.
>>Male Audience Member #1: So the take-away
I was looking for is, I use dry rub--
>>Nathan: Yup.
>>Male Audience Member #1: instead of sauce
when I'm cooking. Is that compatible with
keeping it inside of plastic?
>>Nathan: Sure.
>>Male Audience Member #1: OK.
>>Nathan: Sure, but the other thing is, you
have to--. There's different things you want
to achieve at different parts of cooking the
barbecue. So, our high-tech approach to barbecue
is we smoke. We typically put a dry rub on.
Then we smoke at very low temperature. Then
we cook it sous vide. And then at the end,
we'll either smoke it again to create a bark,
or crust, on the outside, or our best technique
is again, liquid nitrogen and a deep fryer.
So you haven't lived until you've had liquid
nitrogen, deep-fried spareribs.
>>Jeff: Our cooks, they're just totally wondering
how we're gonna do this and how we're gonna
bring in liquid nitrogen. So one thing after
Microsoft--
>>Nathan: Yeah.
>>Jeff: why did you get interested in cooking
and how did you learn all this?
>>Nathan: So, I was interested in cooking
my whole life.
>>Jeff: OK.
>>Nathan: When I was nine, I told my mother
I was gonna cook Thanksgiving dinner and she
let me. I went to the library. I got this
whole stack of books out and, by God, I cooked
Thanksgiving dinner. All by myself.
[laughter]
By today's standards, not so much. For a nine
year old, I think--.
>>Jeff: Yeah, that's pretty ambitious, I gotta
tell ya.
>>Nathan: Well, but I'm pretty ambitious.
So after that, I was a very enthusiastic self-taught
chef for many years. Finally, while I was
working at Microsoft, I decided to go to chef's
school in France. So I went to Bill Gates
and I asked him if I could have a leave of
absence to go to chef's school. This is the
first such, and only, request he's ever gotten.
>>Jeff: What did he say? I'm just curious.
>>Nathan: Well, I had enough leverage. I got
it.
[laughter]
But then, in order to go to the chef's school,
they wouldn't take me unless I had work experience.
So I worked for one night a week at a French
restaurant in Seattle called Rover's.
>>Jeff: OK.
>>Nathan: And a very traditional French chef
ran the place. And I'd go at about noon and
cook all the way through the end of service
and go home. I learned a tremendous amount
there. In fact, when I eventually went to
chef's school, this one morning we had the
assignment of boning ducks. And I'd boned
a lot of ducks at this restaurant.
Not an admission I'd make most places, but
I boned a lot of ducks.
[laughter]
So, this morning the assignment is to do this.
And so I got out there and I start working
away on the ducks. And the chef was teaching
this in French, comes out, "You, you there.
Where did you learn this? You know a duck
like a Frenchman."
[laughter]
>>Jeff: I figure that was a compliment.
>>Nathan: Yes, exactly. I figured that was
a good thing. So then, I was also always interested
in technology and science. I never became
a chef professionally. And there's probably
a parallel universe where I did, but instead,
I became a physicist, actually.
I got a PhD in Physics. I worked for Stephen
Hawking, but then took a leave of absence
for a summer to work on a software project.
And we started a company. And then after a
couple years, Microsoft bought the company
and whatever. So then, finally when I retired
from Microsoft, I started cooking a lot more.
I had a lot more time to cook.
And that's where I really started getting
into all of the real cutting-edge techniques.
Well, what's the highest technology cooking
anyone's doing? And that led to all of this.
>>Male Audience Member: [inaudible].
>>Nathan: Oh yeah. There's--.
>>Jeff: There it goes. So real quick, I went
onto JB Prince before--
>>Nathan: Yup.
>>Jeff: you came in. I was looking for a centrifuge
and they don't have one on their website.
Where can I get one?
>>Nathan: You can get a centrifuge at--
>>Jeff: I'm still looking for one.
>>Nathan: laboratory supply places. But they're
used in every hospital for spinning blood--
>>Jeff: Right.
>>Nathan: including medical tests. So there's
actually a, there's probably three places
in the Bay area that are used centrifuge dealers--
>>Jeff: OK.
>>Nathan: where you can get a used, reconditioned
one. You can also buy them new.
>>Jeff: No, Dennis.
>>Nathan: They're really cool.
>>Jeff: Yeah, we'd love to get one. So, it
looks like we have a lot of questions.
>>Nathan: Yup.
>>Male Audience Member #2: Yeah, my question
would be what are the top three things that
everybody does wrong that the average home
cook could do just slightly differently and
make a big difference?
>>Nathan: Well, "wrong" is a tough thing.
But I'll give you a couple quick tips. I'm
not saying anyone's gonna cook wrong. But
the first one is, if you're making an omelet
or scrambled eggs, there's a tremendous trick
to heed. If you're making a three-egg omelet
or scrambled egg, throw one egg white away.
They're cheap. So, two whole eggs, one yolk.
Enormously improves the texture. There are
people who add butter or cream. You can also
do that. But you get much of the same improvement
and texture as butter or cream just by throwing
one white away. The second thing is, it's
best if you cook it under extremely low heat.
So we cook it in a water bath, or we cook
it in a steam oven. And we cook it to exactly
71 Centigrade, 165 Fahrenheit. You can vary
that a little bit depending, for scrambled
eggs. A little bit hotter for an omelet. And
that lets you do--. Just those two simple
things, temperature control and throwing one
egg white away, totally changes omelets. So,
not everything but it's one trick.
>>Male Audience Member #3: Hi. So, question
about coffee--
>>Nathan: Yeah.
>>Male Audience Member #3: being from Seattle,
of course. I'm sure you experimented with
making the ultimate cup of coffee. What kind
of high-tech things would you recommend applying?
>>Nathan: So, in the case of coffee, there's
a whole coffee community which largely started
in Seattle about 20 years ago and now has
broadened out. So there's lots of cool people
around the world. There's a great guy in London
doing cool coffee work. There's a fantastic
guy in Norway doing cool coffee work.
Some of these people I've met and a lot of
them I only know over the internet. But the
state-of-the-art coffee techniques are all
attention to detail things. I'd love to say
there's a magic machine, but mostly it's super
good temperature control in the machines.
There's a machine called a Synesso, made in
Seattle, which is a fantastic espresso machine.
La Marzocco also has a pretty cool one. The
next interesting thing after good temperature
control, so that means using something called
a PID--a proportional integral differential
temperature controller--anyway, it controls
temperature perfectly. The next thing is something
called pressure profiling. And that's just
now happening.
There's only a few machines. There's probably
no really good machine on the market yet that
really, in a broad way, does pressure profiling.
What that allows you to do is to say the pressure
you make when you make espresso. That goes
over set of--. Now, that's for espresso. Then
there's a half a dozen other things that I
could go into about making the ideal espresso.
For regular coffee, my favorite way to make
it is something called an AeroPress. And it's
like a $29 piece of plastic that you buy on
Amazon. And you know those Super Soaker kinds
of--? Well, it's like a Super Soaker, but
you put it over your coffee cup and you heat
the water to exactly 175 degrees, medium grind,
but a drip grind, not an espresso grind.
And there's a few other things. You wait for
30 seconds and then you plunge it. It's fantastic.
>>Male Audience Member #3: Thank you.
>>Male Audience Member #4: So I had a question
about the lab you set up--
>>Nathan: Yup.
>>Male Audience Member #4: and co-authors
for the books.
>>Nathan: Yup.
>>Male Audience Member #4: So, could you go
into how you selected these folks in the Dream
Team? And what are they doing now that the
book is out?
>>Nathan: So, I realized if I hadn't written
software, I never would have written this
book because most books are one person's singular
vision. And that's really what defines those
books. And one person can write a piece of
software, but usually the best software isn't
written by a single person, 'cause a), there's
only so much a single person can do.
Usually, a small team. A really big team has
a hard time equaling the productivity of a
smaller team. And so, we always wanted like,
six to ten people. It was the ideal size software
team in my view. But I also wasn't afraid
of having a team like that and even having
a larger team of people around it because
I wasn't afraid of that.
As soon as I realized that this book--. Scale
was an important thing for the book. If I
got all of these topics together in one place,
I could really achieve something because people
could learn it all in one place. But if you
only have half of them, you did a little something.
But people still have to scramble to find
the other half.
So I decided at some point, "Hey, this is
gonna be a team project." So I hired a guy
who'd worked at the Fat Duck. It was this
fantastic restaurant in England. Now, he'd
been a chemist in a graduate student at the
University of Washington prior to that. So,
he also understood science a lot. I hired
an editor. Actually, even before I decided
to do the book, from "Scientific American."
I made him the editor-in-chief and then we
just picked people one at a time. All the
photos were taken by me and my assistant.
Although, my assistant wound up taking 90
percent of them. And he was a guy who answered
a Craigslist ad for being my Photoshop guy.
Initially, I thought I only really needed
an assistant to help me with the lights and
to do the Photoshopping.
And this guy had just come out of an art school.
He'd just finished his photography thing,
so not deep experience. But thank God not
deep experience because it allowed us to develop
a style that was really different and unique,
which is what you see in all these pictures.
And what they're doing right now is most of
them still work for me.
I mean, some of them are freelance. They were
graphic artists and would do this picture
or that picture. But most of them still work
for me and we're working on promoting the
book and figuring out what we do next.
>>Male Audience Member #5: Hi. Thanks for
a great talk. I noticed that your tag line
is "a revolution in the art of cooking," and
I think it's patently obvious to everyone
that you've really advanced to science of
cooking in bringing all this together. How
does it change the art? Obviously there's
some art in these pictures. But what do you
think about that?
>>Nathan: OK. Well, there's two answers to
that. The first is engineering underlies art.
There are a bunch of masterpieces that Leonardo
da Vinci created that are lost because he
tried a brand new technique for the paint
and the damn paint fell off the wall.
So, empowering chefs by giving them new techniques--and
there's the kitchen again--it's in a space
that used to be a Harley-Davidson dealership
and service center. And then they moved. And
we still get these guys that look like they
came out of a ZZ Top video coming up and saying,
"Well, where do I get my Hog serviced?" I
say, "Well, they moved down the street."
So, we took it and turned it into this. To
answer your question, the rest of your question,
part of the art comes in enabling art through
science and engineering. Part of it is we
take a lot of effort in the book to discuss
cooking as art. And one of the reasons we
call it "Modernist Cuisine" is we draw a lot
of parallels between modernism, which was
this idea that changed art and architecture
and literature, philosophy in the 19th and
the 20th centuries.
Cooking never got its modernist period, I
argue, until now. And so, we think that in
fact, this is about art. And I'd love to point
out that cooking is an art. Art is about engaging
us through our emotions. And the analogy I
like best is actually to architecture because
architecture is necessary. Painting and sculpture
are not quite as necessary, but you need a
roof over your head.
And so, most buildings in the world are pretty
dull. They're warehouses and they're truly
dull buildings, but they're necessary. Most
meals in the world are the same way. They're
not art. They're necessary because we need
food as fuel for our bodies. But in both food
and architecture, you can create amazing artistic
things that grab your emotions and thrill
people in a way like nothing else can. So.
>>Male Audience Member #5: Thanks.
>>Male Audience Member #6: I was curious if
you went off at all on the tangent of nutrition,
so that you can talk a little bit about--
>>Nathan: Oh, we went off on so many tangents
in this book it's ridiculous. So, one of the
things--. That's sea urchin on cocoa noodles.
So in our thing on heat and energy, everybody
knows that their various electrical appliances
draw watts. Well we put a little biography
of James Watt in to explain why those things
are called watts.
We have a whole chapter called "Food and Health,"
which covers nutrition, sort of. I don't mean
we comprehensively cover nutrition. But we
decided to tackle a very controversial issue,
which is what food is good for you and what
food is not good for you. Because there's
a tremendous amount of popular information
about this, this is often ascribed to medical
science.
But the actual truth of those things which
are really well-proven and those things which
currently there's still significant uncertainty,
that's not communicated very well. So we have
a whole chapter about that and that includes
how to read, if you see a press release that
say there's a risk factor is increased for
this by doing--.
What does that really mean? What does a 95
percent confidence interval mean on one of
those studies? So, one example is some of
the things people say are bad for you, really
do seem to be bad for you. Trans fats really
do seem to be bad for you. Saturated fat in
butter, actually there's very little proof.
In fact, some people would say there's no
proof at all that it's bad for you.
We give a tragic example in the book. There's
this study called the Nurses Study that followed
the health of 86,000 nurses for 25 years.
One sub-group were the margarine eaters. And
in the era, which is mostly the 1970s and
'80s, in this era, they were eating margarine
because they thought it was good for you.
It was polyunsaturated. Then they had another
group that said, damn it, they're gonna eat
butter. The margarine eaters have four times
the death rate of the butter eaters. Because
in that era, although it was very well meaning
to think polyunsaturated must be better for
you than saturated, there was no proof.
And the way they got the polyunsaturated was
the cheapest way, which was to make trans
fats. And so, this is one of these things
where a little knowledge actually can be dangerous.
Yup.
>>Male Audience Member #7: Hello. Thank you
for your presentation. I'm a fellow physicist
and you talk a lot about temperature control.
>>Nathan: Yup.
>>Male Audience Member #7: I would like it
if you could expand a little bit on the spectrum
of actually the heat-producing elements in
barbecues, or kitchens, because what I don't
understand when I came to the U.S. and I saw
people grilling on a flame, how does that
change the spectrum? And are there benefits
to doing that?
>>Nathan: OK. So, the simple answer to that
is no. But here's the thing. Most traditional
approaches to cooking start with a very high
heat source. Originally, that was a fire.
But you never want to cook the food as hot
as the fire is.
OK, it would burn. The other thing is most
food is mostly water. And as a result, you
can't actually make the food hotter than the
boiling point of water until you've dried
out the outside at least. So a typical cooking
technique says, "I have this super high heat
and then I cook with it by timing, very carefully,
how long I put it in that high heat and how
long I take it off."
That's true whether you're cooking in a pot,
you're cooking on a grill, you're cooking
on other things. The more modern approach,
which we describe in the book, just says,
"No, screw it. You should cook with low temperature."
So, if you want to cook meat medium rare,
that means you wanna make the meat about 130
Fahrenheit.
So, the way we do that, we cook at about 132
Fahrenheit. So we use a very low temperature
source. Low temperature steam or water in
a water bath. It takes longer for the heat
to soak in, but never can overcook it. If
you forget it an hour, it doesn't matter.
If you're a little bit early, it doesn't matter
either.
You're only off by a fraction of a degree.
So that's a very fundamental thing. Now, you
ask about grilling. Grilling is cooking with
infrared rays. Those infrared rays mostly
come over other hot things. And simply a gas
flame is a poor way to do it. That's why most
good gas grills have a metal plate in there
that the flame goes on.
And it's the heat from that plate that is
going on to your food. In the case of barbecue
coals, what looks like fire around them is
actually little particles that are being heated
up incandescence. And the blueness of the
flame has nothing to do with the spectrum.
There is a thing where the hotter something
gets, the bluer the color is.
It's nowhere near hot enough to be blue. It's
a chemical bluingness that creates that. More
answer maybe than you wanted, but there you
go.
>>Jeff: Any other questions? All right. Nathan,
anything else you'd like to say?
>>Nathan: No, I think that pretty much covers
it.
>>Jeff: All right. Well thanks so much for
coming. Love the cookbook.
[applause]